so I think the threat today's terrorism  threat still includes sleeper cells  al-qaeda all the kind of major terrorist  organizations that you would think of  but we're also very focused now on  homegrown violent extremists which are  people who are largely here already in  the United States big cities small towns  coast-to-coast and these are people who  are largely radicalized online how do  you keep them from becoming radicalized  online  well the online issue is a challenge  right terrorism today moves at the speed  of social media part of it is engaging  with social media companies in a way to  try to get them to do certain things  they can do voluntarily in a Silicon  Valley being helpful we are getting much  better cooperation than we used to  I think everybody's learning I think  there's a view that this is a shared  threat shared not just between law  enforcement and intelligence but shared  between government and the private  sector